well as covet cases surge all across las
vegas many are having to quarantine and
miswork and this is really hitting the
local restaurant industry pretty hard
after already dealing with staff
shortages sasha lofta spoke with two
business owners tonight who are having
to cut hours just to give their current
employees a break sasha
denise the owner of this restaurant here
says he's had to cut back those hours
every single day as these shortages
continue he and other business owners in
las vegas say it's really the only way
they can give the employees they have a
break
it's been very challenging angela reyes
shares the recent struggles he's seen as
a restaurant owner in las vegas we
cannot have our full staff
working just because of the fact that
everybody is getting sick his business
tres casuelas has had to cut daily hours
in half due to a lack of staff the
latest hurdle amid the kovid 19 pandemic
the staff is just tired john elena says
metro pizza is also feeling the effects
as all locations are closing an extra
day every week for the first time in
over 40 years all to give employees a
break you know from the strip to local
local restaurants like ours
are feeling feeling the
shift they both say these kinds of
cutbacks are an unfortunate result of
chronic labor shortages a recent survey
conducted by square financial services
found 21 percent of restaurant positions
remain unfilled as we start 20-22 that
coupled with a recent surge in covid
cases really creates a one-two punch
there's not enough staff for us to be
able to
to keep any more hours open elena says
it's anything but ideal but he's doing
his best to adapt every day he and reyes
both believe valley businesses and
community members will get through this
all together
naraya says he luckily hasn't had an
employee test positive at this location
yet he and other business owners tell me
they really want to remind customers to
stay patient as staff really tries to
pick up the slack as this shortage
continues reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now